is in his second year of training as a
metal worker
he's doing his training at a vocational
center in berlin's kreitzberg district
he was sent here by germany's employment
agency
at the job center they told me this
place would give me a chance
and that i should take it it made me
want to really try hard
and go higher and higher
one of the top priorities is to restore
the trainee's confidence
many have dropped out of school or
applied for numerous jobs without
success
the items argan some say they're not
ready for training
others say they can't be taught we show
that isn't true if you make an effort
with this group
you can help them you can motivate them
and then they succeed
the center trains around 450 people at a
time
for occupations ranging from chef to
hairdresser or florist
social workers are on hand to support
the trainees and the center offers extra
german courses
many of the instructors are themselves
not native germans
like kevin moore from the u.s but only
german is spoken in the kitchen
outstanding as a foreigner i know this
can sometimes be difficult but that's
just one thing we all have to go through
you learn to express yourself in german
that's when land
of the londish bracket is also driven
some projections suggest that half of
young people in germany will soon come
from a migrant background
today the center's focus on immigrant
youth is something of an exception
but staff here are convinced that that
will change as this growing group
becomes ever more important
for the german labor market
you